الجمهوريون متفائلون بامكانيه الفوز بمجلس
النواب في ما تنتظرهم معركه شرسه اثناء
محاوله قلب مجلس الشيوخ لمصلحتهم السيطره
على مجلس الشيوخ تتوقفوا على ثلاث ولايات
هي جورجيا ونفاده وابن سلفانيا خبراء حيث
يسعى شغل المناصب الديمقراطيه الى اعاده
انتخابهم في جورج
فيما يتنافس الحزبان على المقعد الشاغر في
تنس الفينا والذي كان يشغله الجمهوريه
المتقاعد تومي واي حزب سيفوز باثنين من
الثلاثه مقاعد ستزدادوا فرصه وبقوه ليكون
حزب الاغلبيه
وبحسب واشنطن بوك افضل فرصه للجمهوريين
نظرا الى ان الحزب الجمهوريه قدم ولاول
مره منذ سنوات مرشحا معتدلا نسبيا هو
المدعي العام السابق ادم في جورجيا يحاول
الجمهوريه سوكر انت زعل من السيناتور في
عنوانك الذي حصل عليه بجوله الاعاده العام
الماضي فيما الامل كبيره في بنسلفانيا
بتمكن المرشح الجمهوري محمد اوز من الفوز
رغم استطلاعات الراي التي اظهرت تخلفه عن
جون فترمان الديمقراطي ولايه ويسكونسن تعد
ثانيه افضل فرصه لديمقراطيين و تشهد تقدم
لمرشحهم منديلا باانس على السيناتور
الجمهوريه جون سينا في اريزونا ايضا توجد
فرصه جيده للديمقراطيين وفق الاستطلاعات
من نصيب المرشح ماركلي في مواجهه المرشح
المدعوم من ترامب ليك ماستر